Clara say there are a lot of rumors
about the future of Nashville may be
headed to CMT what do you know about
those reports I've been seen flying
around and it's really encouraging I
don't know any more than you do dislike
I'm really excited whatever happens I'm
so excited would you come back to the
show if it did get picked up on another
network yeah I mean it's a wonderful
wonderful show as long as it represents
national the city as what it actually is
because I think that's the most
important thing it's not just a
television show this is like country
music history that had to be shocking
maybe or really sad when you did get the
news of the cancellation how did you
react it was a shock but the ABC game is
cool grey is and I'm really grateful I
mean and you can't take anything in this
industry personally we do that it will
you alive so I'm really grateful to the
ABC right for the Lions Gate for all
they doing I want the Nashes to keep
going with the bring back Nashville with
really important guys you guys have done
so much that petition that everybody
signed it's almost up to 200,000 we're
feeling the love very grateful